être concentré être habile avec ses
doigts
voilà les secrets pour emporter une
partie de fifa le célèbre jeu de
football sur console s'est invité à la
première édition du montigny games des
trente personnes étaient inscrites pour
ce challenge et c'est donc gilles
l'entente qui a été le meilleur
rapprochement c'est cool c'est la
première fois devient un événement comme
ça j'ai jamais fait donc franchement ce
que cous le majorquin aura d'autres en
plus des jeux sur console les visiteurs
avaient accès à des jeux d'arcade de
simulation en passant par le
traditionnel baby foot ou le retrogaming
l'événement se voulait
intergénérationnel on a vu aujourd'hui
en fait les familles entières venir mans
c'est ça qui est important parce que des
fois on peut avoir
des parents qui viennent ou les enfants
mais là toute la famille est venue
ensemble pour venir jouer chacun trouvé
son
gérer son jeu delphine et gilles sont
venus en famille et ont pu effectuer un
petit retour vers le passé
[Musique]
ah non je t'aimais cavale
rappelle beaucoup de souvenirs de 2
c'est l'adolescence l'adolescence de
grandes soirées passées devant les
consoles et les pommes temps on pouvait
pas terminer on pouvait pas enregistrées
c'est bien qu'un jour on vient se
souvenir les enfants maintenant il
enregistre et continue lendemain entre
est ce que nous quand ça s'arrêtait ça
s'arrêtait cette première édition du
montigny games des initiés par le
conseil municipal des jeunes semblent
avoir tenu toutes ses promesses en
faisant le bonheur des amateurs de jeux
[Musique]